so okay I mean you know you ask any
farmer with this season now look at you
like you're crazy and there's stored
stuff and there's a you know nothing but
in fact there's a lot in season now and
and what we're harvesting out of the
greenhouse and out of these winter
tunnels out in the you know 50 cent per
yard little fabric tunnels outside and
it mind you it's 20 18 degrees outside
right now but we're harvesting mosh
lettuce greens and kale and Swiss chard
and we're harvesting Jerusalem
artichokes which had been in the ground
since last summer and are literally
sugar so tonight you come to blue hill
you'll have sliced raw drew some
artichokes and drew some artichoke puree
on these beautiful salads that are a
part of you know our agriculture only 20
miles north of here and then we're also
harvesting pigs and eggs and and sheep
and I mean on and on i mean the winter
agriculture for animals is like it's a
no-brainer around here you know so we
tend to have a lot more meat on the menu
in the winters and we tend to have lots
of salads and root vegetables for for
this time of year but but I'm also you
know I'm not like a period I'm not
squeaky clean like I'm you know I don't
want to you know I would hate to think
that like I'm trying to talk about an
agriculture about bad about an
experience at Blue Hill that's you know
like a shaker village 100 years ago you
know like we have to live like they live
then to be pure about locality and about
sustainability I did since that doesn't
make any sense to me you know we have a
big food chain that in some sense is is
is delicious too you know it's very
efficient and to the extent that i can
know the farmer in california or florida
and texas or beyond you know great but I
indulge in that too i love tropical
fruit at this time of year you know i
love avocados you know we got some of
those in I mean I there's nothing that
is worse than being you know pedantic
about this thing for the sake of it you
know the locavore movement you know is
something that's very popular now and i
love it i'm is great people of you know
trying to do the all these meals at a
than 100 miles or a hundred fifty miles
from you know these food sheds its great
but for a restaurant that you're trying
to appeal to the most sophisticated
demanding clientele in Westchester
County in New York City than anywhere in
the world you know I don't I don't think
there's a problem with varieties
question of percentages so in August if
I'm serving you tropical fruit we got we
got issues but for right now you don't
mind indulging and in fruits and
vegetables a little bit from around the
world so there you go that flies in the
face of all the whole sustainability
local thing but in I don't care it's
confusing the situation but I think
confusing instructively